Corey Hajim: I'm so excited
to be here today with Carlos.
He's a leader I really admire,
because he uses his business acumen
to take on big challenges,
and he's done so in his home country
of Peru and beyond.
He has built a group
of affordable schools called Innova,
and they serve about 65,000 students.
He also has a chain
of maternity health-care clinics,
he's taken on infrastructure projects
and public-private partnerships,
among other things.
Now I have to tell you,
it's taken me a couple of years
to convince Carlos to come speak with us
here at TED.
He's not really a spotlight guy.
You're more likely to find him
doing deep research,
"Undercover Boss" style,
than talking about his work
in the glossy pages of business magazines.
Not that he doesn't deserve
to be there -- he really does.
And so we're so lucky
to have him here with us today
to tell us more about
what he’s done, how he’s done it
and what we can learn from it.
So thanks for being here, Carlos.
Carlos Rodriguez-Pastor:
Thanks, Corey, glad to be here.
(Applause)
CH: Let's start with education.
What was the problem you saw there?
CRP: So let me just put it in context
and tell you a little bit about Peru.
Peru is a middle-income country.
It's right in the middle
of South America, on the Pacific Coast.
And from 1990 to 2017,
we grew our economy close to five percent,
so it's one of the fastest-growing
economies in the world,
and certainly the fastest
in South America.
At the same time,
the poverty rate came down
from 55 percent to 25 percent.
So we were feeling pretty good
about all the things
that were going on in Peru,
and it seemed like there was
a possibility that eventually,
25 years from now,
we could become a developed country.
But there are a lot
of hurdles along the way
that we have to overcome
in order to get there.
And some of them include the basic things
that happen in most developing countries,
like education,
health care, infrastructure.
Now during the same time,
I remember, in about 2007,
they did an assessment
of all the public school teachers,
and the results were not very encouraging.
A very small percentage passed basic math,
basic reading comprehension.
And in the year 2000,
we were ranked last in the PISA rankings,
which are these rankings
for 15-year-old kids
in various countries.
And 12 years later,
we were also dead last.
So despite all this growth,
we had a real issue,
to improve our education system.
And so we decided to get involved,
to understand what was going on,
because it was obvious that we could not
become a developed country
without having world-class
education and health care.
CH: And you said that the public schools
were in rough shape.
We wanted to share a photo
of the state of the public schools.
And you were saying
it's not just the way it looks,
it was what was going on inside.
CRP: So this is a typical public school
we saw when we started our research.
You can see it kind of looks dark outside,
but what's worse
is what's going on inside.
Kids aren't learning.
Low attendance,
low engagement and poor quality.
And as a result of these public schools,
a lot of small, informal private schools
started popping up all over the country.
And they were just as bad
as some of the public schools.
And they have catchy names, right?
(Laughter)
CRP: And here's another one
with a catchy name.
(Laughter)
CH: Some of you may have gone there.
CRP: And so when we did
our "Undercover Boss" research,
we went to one of these schools.
I remember going
with a couple of colleagues
and asking a lot of questions
to the person who gave us the tour.
She didn't believe that we were parents
with kids looking to go
into those schools.
She was getting suspicious
and asked us to please leave,
because she was the director
and also the owner.
And before we left,
we asked her one final question,
and that is "Why did you decide
to do a private school?"
And her answer surprised us.
She said, "Because it's more profitable
than a Chinese food restaurant."
Now, sadly, this is the level
of commitment
in a lot of these private schools.
So we decided it's time
to do something about this.
CH: Not quite the right motivation.
Education is so complicated,
so when you started this journey,
what were your goals?
CRP: I didn't know anything
about education,
except from being a student
and a consumer of it for many years,
so the first thing I did --
and this is a true story --
I watched every TED Talk on education.
CH: I promise, it's not a plant.
CRP: And then started reaching out
to the different people
I thought were interesting,
and were doing wonderful things there.
I grew up partly in California,
I worked on Wall Street,
so I started looking at my contact list,
and I remembered an innovation company
that, when I grew up in California,
was always behind a lot
of the product innovation.
So I called them up, IDEO.
And with them, along with Sal Khan,
who we were introduced with,
and some academics
from Berkeley and from Harvard,
we put together a system to really try
to change education in our country.
So in Peru, we have
eight million K-12 kids,
and our target was about
1.6 million of those kids over time,
which we call the emerging middle class.
And what we codesigned
was a system that had
four characteristics.
The first one, it had to be affordable.
And by affordable,
I mean 150 dollars a month
for the regular students,
and for our scholarship students,
one dollar a day.
Second, it had to have
academic excellence.
These are schools
that have to move the needle.
Otherwise, it doesn't really make sense.
And they're well-designed,
they were modern, they were safe.
Third, we wanted
a project that was scalable.
Not just to build one or two schools,
but why not aspire to build
hundreds of schools,
and perhaps cross borders
and go to other countries.
And fourth, we thought
it was very important
that the schools be sustainable.
And "sustainable" is our code word
for "profitable."
CH: So profitability,
let's talk a little bit about that.
Why is that so important?
Because we talked about the woman
and the Chinese restaurant
and that she didn't seem
properly motivated.
So why, for you,
is profitability so important?
CRP: I think it's very important,
because that way,
we can keep building more schools
and we can go across borders
and keep this project going.
You know, it's very ambitious
for the teachers,
so I imagine someday,
in some neighboring country, you know,
a mom and dad having a conversation
about where to send their kids to school,
and maybe one of the parents says,
"What about that school
where the Peruvians are teaching?"
So imagine that,
going from last in education in the world
to being the teachers of our region.
That would do so much
to the self-esteem of our country, Peru.
CH: That goes back
to what you said about sustainability:
profitability, for you,
equals sustainability.
There must be some trade-offs
that you're making
to make these schools reach profitability.
What are some of those trade-offs?
CRP: When you start with a fixed price
that you can charge,
you can't do everything.
So sometimes, our students
have to share tablets,
we don't have swimming pools,
but we have very nice spaces
where kids can learn,
they can collaborate.
We use a blended learning model,
which is solo learning
and classroom learning.
This is an image of one of our schools,
and the next is an image
of our rock-star math teacher,
in middle school,
Sal Khan.
It's a funny story --
when Sal came to visit us
in Peru many years ago,
when we were just starting out,
he came to our math lab,
where we have 60 kids and one monitor,
looking and helping
the kids that need help.
I was talking to Sal
and a couple of other people with him.
As you know, he never appears
in his videos,
it's just his voice.
And one of the young kids said,
"Hey, that sounds like Sal Khan.
Is that Sal?"
And before you knew it, word got around,
and a huge line of kids
asking Sal for his autograph.
You know, their math teacher.
(Applause)
CH: It’s a really wonderful story,
a nice rock star to have stop by.
So let’s shift gears a little
towards healthcare.
What did you want to do there,
and what have you done in that space?
CRP: Healthcare was as broken
as the education system.
Maybe the slight difference
is in education,
you have to have
a real sense of urgency --
otherwise, you miss the entire generation.
And in healthcare,
we are fairly lucky that we still have
a young population,
so perhaps we have a little more time
to go through this.
But, you know, our healthcare system
is universal healthcare.
Eight million informal workers
have that from the government,
and then four million pay a tax
of the formal economy,
that's slightly better,
but this is a typical picture.
You make a long line.
Sometimes, it's hours.
There’s a lot of informal ...
just like the private schools,
and they'll offer two-for-one
medical procedures ...
CH: Bring a friend?
CRP: Exactly.
It’s not good quality.
So again, we teamed up with IDEO
and a lot of different institutions
to design something
for the emerging middle class.
The first call in Peru is pharmacies.
So if you're sick,
you go to the pharmacy first,
because you'd waste a whole day,
and you really can't afford
to leave work for a day.
So right around the time
we started Innova,
we got involved in buying
a small chain of pharmacies
that today has 2,300 locations
throughout the entire country,
including the most remote areas
you can imagine, in the Amazon,
where you have to go
in canoes and ships to get there.
And as an extension of that,
we also developed a clinic called Aviva,
where we give good quality,
about 40 to 60 beds
in each one of our clinics,
and we're focusing
on the most important part of life,
which is birth.
This particular clinic in Lima
had the most births
of the entire country last year.
And so now, we have an alternative
to give good health care
to the emerging middle class.
CH: Now another thing
you've dipped your toe into,
in pretty big ways --
infrastructure, and that's a whole
different kind of project.
And you did it through
a public-private partnership.
Can you talk a little bit
about how that came about
and how it worked?
CRP: So years ago,
I remember going to Arequipa,
which is the second-largest city in Peru,
with my father and my grandfather.
And in that visit,
hearing about a bridge
that was going to be built.
Years later, I went back,
and I heard about the bridge again.
And it turns out that this bridge
has been on the planning board
for over 50 years,
and it never got done.
It was because this party was in power,
whatever the reason,
it just didn't get done.
So a few years ago,
the government came up
with a very clever plan.
It's called "Projects for Taxes."
And what that does
is it allows companies
to use up to 30 percent
of the taxes they pay --
instead of paying it
to the central government,
to use it for projects
that the community needs.
They have to be pre-approved ...
by the government,
but then you kind of do it yourself.
So we teamed up with the largest
beer company in Peru
and one of the large
mining companies, and together,
we put 100 million dollars of the taxes
we would have paid
to the central government,
and we built this bridge,
which connects one side
of the city to the other.
It was done on time
and on budget.
No corruption, no drama,
the bridge is still standing.
(Laughter)
And now, you know,
thousands of people
every single day use this bridge
and, as a result,
improve the quality of their life.
This is a very good example
of how private-public
partnerships can work.
And what we've done in our group
is we've set a goal
to have an iconic project,
like that bridge you just saw,
in every one of the 25 states across Peru.
So far, we've completed five,
in five different states,
so we have 20 to go,
but we're excited about that.
CH: When I read about that,
I thought that was such
an interesting project
and an interesting partnership.
So a lot of the businesses
you've started and your projects
are focused on the middle class.
So why are you so focused
on that particular segment
of the population?
CRP: The middle class,
for the last couple of decades,
has been the fastest-growing
segment of the country.
It was, in a way, low-hanging fruit.
A lot of services were unmet,
and so we tried to develop
answers for those.
And it was also a way to scale fast,
because a lot of the emerging middle class
is in urban settings.
So you can actually go
from zero to relevance
relatively fast.
What we're working on now
is what we call the next frontier,
which is rural Peru,
which is still a big part
of the population,
and all the cities in our country
that have 20,000 or less people.
But really, the reason we got involved
in areas like education and healthcare
is that the government wasn't delivering.
If you're familiar with Peru,
and you know what's been going on,
we've had six presidents in six years.
Now the last president
before the current one
had so many cabinet changes
that on average,
every five days, we'd have
a new cabinet minister.
So ask yourself,
if you're running an organization ...
You can't get even through the weekend.
Maybe Monday, he's here,
Friday, they're gone.
So it's very hard
to get things accomplished
from the government side.
So what should we do?
Should we wait for that Batman
president to show up?
Or should we get involved?
And I have to admit that for many years,
I would attend conferences
and would do what a lot of people do,
the golf clap,
and then go back to your work,
and say, "I'd like to help, but ..."
And then the next year, another golf clap,
and, kind of, the same thing.
But we really believe
that the private sector
has a very important role.
It's 80 percent
of the economy in our country.
And we can really push the leaders along
to take on the most difficult,
most challenging problems in the country.
Because education takes
20, 25 years or more to solve.
A political term may be
only four or five years.
So I think we have more staying power.
And we don't pretend to run
the whole education system
or to educate the eight million kids
that go to schools.
But if we do our job correctly,
maybe we can put it up
at the top of the agenda,
maybe we can show how it can be done.
We can continue to partner
with the government,
and together, as a result,
make a better country.
CH: I mean, a lot
of the things you've done,
you've stepped in where government
has fallen short.
Do you feel like you're letting them
off the hook, though?
Or do you feel they're responding to this?
CRP: I would say it's the opposite.
We're putting pressure
to get these things resolved.
I believe that,
by showing what can be done,
perhaps we can inspire them
to work together,
not just with us, but with all the other
fine companies that we have in our country
that do world-class things.
But we can't just fold our hands and wait,
in the hope that a savior
someday comes and helps us.
And I think that's what's behind
all these projects.
CH: There was one more picture
you wanted me to share with the audience,
of the protests in Peru.
Why did you want me
to share this with them?
CRP: This is a horrible picture.
It's horrible for a number of reasons --
it hurts our tourism,
and the image of the country, etc.
But what makes me really sad
about this picture --
and this happened not too long ago,
a few weeks ago --
is it's Peruvians against Peruvians.
And I think we both want the same things.
We want a better life,
we want opportunity.
We want the ability to reach our dreams
and go as far as we can go.
And when I see this, I wonder,
is this just Peru?
Or can this happen in other communities?
And how can we stop this from happening?
So I have some suggestions.
The first one is find out what are
the most difficult challenges
in your community and your country,
and try to understand them.
Get involved.
Put a sense of urgency, raise your hand.
Not some day.
Make "some day" today.
Second is
seek out help.
Most likely, the problems have been
solved somewhere else.
And you can add to that
and continue to build.
And the last thing
is have a mindset where you're trying
to make the pie bigger.
And even if you come
from the private sector, I guarantee you,
if you focus on making the pie
bigger for your country,
you'll do well yourself.
Our objective is to make Peru
the best place to raise a family
in Latin America.
Our long-term objective is to push Peru
to become a developed country.
And that's really hard.
And then, it comes to execution.
And this is where we lose
a lot of that impetus,
a lot of that "let's get it done,"
because it's hard.
And what we found out is that,
when you have a big challenge,
many times, you'll say "yes, but."
And that "but" is followed
by lots and lots of excuses.
In Spanish, it's "sí, pero."
"Pero" is the "but."
So we decided to make it a little easier.
And why not change that "o" to a "u,"
and wake up every morning,
and say "sí, Perú."
(Laughter)
(Applause)
CH: Well, I think you can see
why I admire this guy. (Laughs)
Thank you so much, Carlos,
for all that you've shared with us.
I think we all have a lot of work to do,
so thank you.
CRP: Thank you, Corey.
(Applause)
(Cheers and applause)